hello everybody and welcome to let's
play the rake back to asylum now this is
a game that I don't know if I found or
someone suggested probably someone
suggested to me but either way it's made
on the same engine that the Slenderman
shadow games you know Slenderman seven
Street prison all that so I'm actually
quite curious I mean I'm not sure what
game engine this is but I think it's
becoming a bit more popular these days
the rake back to asylum and don't ask me
with that [ __ ] up wait a minute that's
that's the same flashlight that used in
Slenderman shadow wait a minute what is
this all about what is this oh and it's
actually got a hold down the mouse to
get the light on Oh what did I just get
myself into I didn't even see a
screenshot of this thing wha
hi
someone who be banging who be banging
what's with these stone slab beds ooh in
on the middle of nowhere
hello alright pretty sparse showings
pipes that seem to go up from the ground
and then immediately back down into the
ground don't know what the point of that
is but I won't question this building
structural structural design just yet
I'll wait for weird things to happen
before I do that cuz game logic is very
important to me now what's dis den huh
this looks like it might have taken
quite a few elements from Klenner prison
Oh blood
buh hahahahaha I know that sound
I know exactly that sound that was the
sound wait
oh no oh wait get your guests get where
where did that sound come from oh yeah
okay all your guess is in that was the
screaming head from cry of fear Bing
bong right in the first episode that was
that exact scream I'd recognize that
anywhere it haunted my dreams we got
here actually kind of I'm intrigued I'm
not sure what's going on I'm not sure if
I'm supposed to find something fun
running away from something kind of
annoying that I have to hold that leg
down more blood it's always a good sign
means I'm getting close to some injured
person who needs my help it's the only
reason I'm in here right right right
right yeah right
all right um more blood I'm getting to
lots of blood there's nothing even
behind these doors they're just sticking
out in the middle of nowhere huh maybe
this game came out before prison and
it's prison took elements from this game
not by not I really don't know what the
point is is expecting at least a
jump-scare by now haha recognize it now
alright so someone's screaming in the
distance and he must be in pain from the
amount of blood that he's losing oh god
what are you where are you kidding me
what did what was that oh ha ha ha hi I
was not expecting anything to actually
happen good golly what was I look like a
werewolf
ah man I entered a bathroom of sorts
none of the rooms in this place make any
sense good golly huh I'm not prepared
for that still don't know what I'm
looking for if anything oh okay I'm okay
I'm okay still moving forward I hear
clicking in the background now they know
you're not gonna are you not gonna you
know you're not you're not okay
I'll just okay quickly hey buddy
hahaha what are you doing hey there what
do you do hi uh you gonna kill me
if I touch you you're gonna kill me
aren't you oh you're looking at me hmm
yeah oh you're not so tough I'll get out
of here give lift bro look at your
scrawny little arms I'm not sure the
deal is with that guy oh he's gone now
okay oh good shut up
we all got problems okay I'm not sure if
I'm going in a circle or if I'm going in
a maze it seems to be very maze like now
I kind of want to know what the game
engine is just because you know I wonder
how simple how easy it is to set up a
game and I'd be very interested in that
sort of stuff
I'm always interested in you know the
tools in the a lot of the technology
behind making games in
that intrigues me if anyone knows what
this is please write in the comments
below also how much wood would a
woodchuck chuck if a woodchuck could
chuck with more blood follow the blood
that's always a good scratch T in life
help this is a bad strategy okay that
monster whatever it is doesn't seem to
be threatening I'm not sure this said
this was version 2 of the game so I'm
thinking there has to be something to it
an objective of anything Heller more
blood maybe if I follow this blood it
leaves a door smashed up it wait what's
that why would I have the input what
it's time to escape
oh I'm on this gave promise home to this
island okay how do I pick you up space
II how do i how do I get you I want to I
want to have you in my life I want to
have you in my life
phone I'm doing the phone how does I get
to you pressing buttons what got what
what did I just do
no huh you press zero it puts your
keychain right away okay I can't seem to
pick this thing up I don't know what the
deal is but uh it said time to escape
maybe that's just you know telling me
now I got to go back the way I came
okay oh I can run I can okay
we look at me going so fast now
anybody out there and a body rock your
body
quickly quickly quickly anybody
mm-hm I don't know I seriously don't
know what the deal is with with this
game what was that did I hear something
or did I imagine that no I'm just gonna
wander through here get out of the
bathroom and go this way or for my
Canadian friends the washroom for my
European friends uh I don't I don't know
I don't know what you call the bathroom
the toilet la toilette I don't know my
am I being rude rude good oh I don't I
might have taken a wrong turn there I'm
not sure which way I just went cuz this
definitely doesn't look no what did I
got mo huh what what I did don't don't
how did that do Dan oh I I hate it when
you ask monsters not to kill you and
then they just kill you isn't that just
a pain in the ass can't believe it the
nerve of that guy alright anyway I don't
have enough time to take a second a
crack at it I don't know I don't think
there's much more to it anymore aleix
peck ting like some substance in it came
I I mean I appreciate a game like this
that kind of just drops you in a thing
it doesn't tell you what to do but you
know at least with like the original
Slender you have an objective that I
think it was just wander the halls so
you find the phone and then try to make
your way back
that doesn't seem to be a reward you
know it doesn't seem to be an
explanation for the monster I'm not
knocking the makers at all I'm just
saying that usually this is what you
expect and I think that's that would
improve it if there was some sort of
thing like an incentive or at least you
know I didn't really read in the
beginning hang on let me let hang on
hey what save wha say wood maybe I'm
just I might be talking a bit too much
you know what I'm gonna I'm gonna I'm
going to I'm going to hang on he's away
no I don't want to exit the game all
right I'll be back in a second friends
three two one Bing okay a man returns to
the asylum where he was locked up ten
years ago to search the cell phone of a
friend killed by the rake a mysterious
creature the cell phone okay ignore what
I said all before that explains more I
wasn't paying attention cuz I was doing
my intro so I'm the [ __ ]
so I forgive me makers of the game there
is an objective there is something an
equation I didn't see it and now I feel
bad so give this game a try on yourself
I'm not gonna give it another I'm not
gonna have enough time you saw how long
it took to just get to where I was so if
you guys want to give it a try
links in the description below or is it
was this one of the hard to find ones
this might have been the game that I
only got like off a rapid share link I
don't know I'll try to find it if it's
not there then I couldn't find it so if
it's not in the description below I
couldn't find it but go hunt for it
yourself use Google and all that so
anyway thank you all so much for
watching click the links in the dirt
Asians for more videos that I've done
and as always I will see you in the next
video bye bye